(audience cheers)
Please everybody,
welcome my dear friend, Amirah Kassem!
Hi, happy birthday!
Can you tell everybody
where you got the inspiration for these cakes?
'Cause I think the story's so great.
Yes, totally.
Well, my entire life, my business, my everything
is inspired actually by birthdays.
And the joy it brings to celebrate with people together,
for all of that.
And the one memory that I always have,
apart from you know, cake moment,
is a pinata moment.
I grew up in Mexico, and that was just the most-
Yeah!
(audience laughs)
That was just the most fun part.
You know, going up to something
and knowing that there's surprises inside
and getting to break it open
and we're all hitting it to see.
I don't know, there was such a fun moment to me
that I wanted to combine it with my other love of cake.
You know, at first I put big candies in it.
It didn't really work, they all got stuck.
And somehow, we went smaller, smaller, smaller candies
and we got to sprinkles.
Literally, just a lot of sprinkles.
So that when you cut the cake open,
it really is a pinata.
It pours out.
(audience cheers)
It's mellifluous.
All right, well, Amirah,
what kind of cake are we making today?
Okay, well I know you love daisies, so...
I do, they're my favorite flower and my nickname.
Connecting our flowers,
we're making daisy cakes.
So I'm gonna walk you through it.
We have started by already stacking
a few colors here.
You could always do any fun colors of food coloring.
And have our cream cheese frosting here.
And by the way, if you aren't great at baking,
but you still think this is fun,
start with a box mix cake.
Like, you can literally do this at home on your own,
and it's super fun.
For this one, we're doing five layers,
but you could definitely do six layers,
which is our signature one.
There you go.
Fill it with sprinkles now.
Yeah, you can just pour it all in.
And don't be scared.
The more, the better.
And just quickly, I've domed this one
just so we have the little flower pot.
But I really believe that it should be
more about the mess and the fun.
Because you can cover it in sprinkles
and you love it anyway.
So right now, we're crumb coating,
which means we're just doing a thin layer of frosting
on the outside.
Okay, Amirah.
(audience laughs)
I think I'm gonna...
Oh, oh, I know how to fix it!
Ready? You guys close your eyes.
(audience laughs)
Drew is the most amazing, look at what she's done!
(Drew laughs and audience applauds)
I mean, look at this! Perfect!
Thank you.
What are you talking about?
Yours is perfect.
I mean...
We're just gonna completely skip to Drew's level.
There you go, so.
Perfect right here.
She has now taught us how to frost
the outside of a cake.
That's right.
With so much grace and poise.
And we have here is our little cookie crumbs,
our chocolate cookie crumbs.
I just put them in a bag, smash them up.
You could do this for anything, and we're gonna do-
Yep, yep, exactly.
Oh, right, the adhesive.
I've just got a little glue, AKA frosting.
Your frosting is truly one of the best frostings
that has ever existed in the cake industry.
And I do think your secret weapon is cream cheese.
Yes! Exactly!
(audience cheers)
Cream cheese!
I'm going a slightly different route than you.
Mine's interpretative.
I think yours is artistic.
(Drew screams)
So I made chocolate flowers here,
that we can just, they're very, very dainty
because they're chocolate flowers,
but you could also, if you break it,
do you know what's great, you could just eat it.
Drew, I think that you're crushing it.
Thank you.
Well, I am crushing it, but not in the right way.
(audience laughs)
Well, it is time to cut the cake.
Cut the cake! Cut the cake!
Cut the cake!
Now I've also learned that you need to,
the first cut is the deepest.
(audience laughs)
Literally.
Yes!
(audience cheers)
Cheers!
Woo!
(audience cheers)
Amirah.
I love you so much.
Happy birthday.
(siren blares)
(audience cheers)
That means it's giveaway time.
All right, at first we made a flower theme cake
and flowers are perfect for any birthday celebration
and Venus Et Fleur has beautiful arrangements
that are perfect for gifting.
So everyone in our audience
is getting $150 gift card.
(audience cheers)
And by the way, hi, Devon.
(audience laughs)
These flowers...
Actually, here, come and stand here.
Sorry Devon, oopsy daisy.
I bet women fall into you all the time.
And these flowers last a very long time.
And to match, we have a copy of "Rebel Homemaker,"
which I wrote with Pilar Valdes,
going to all of you guys too.
(audience cheers)
So everyone in the audience gets a copy.
All right, be sure to catch "Foodtastic,"
streaming on Disney Plus,
and get all of Amirah's products
at Williams-Sonoma and her website,
and everything should be a flower shop world.
You'll be happier in it.
(upbeat music)